[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
hey what's up I'm Kim HD here all right
so we're back at it again those of you
who are new here since the last one this
is a bit of a social experiment so if I
were to ask you which camera is better
the iPhone 13 Pro or the Asus Zenfone 8.
I think I have a hunch as to which one
would probably win we all know what
smartphone cameras we think we like and
don't like but that's heavily influenced
by confirmation bias so if I show you a
photo that you know is an iPhone versus
some other random phone you don't like
as much then your eye will automatically
be drawn to every little thing that's
better about just the iPhone photo but
what if we do a comparison where we
remove the labels and you don't know
which one is the iPhone and which one is
the alternate or better yet bring in 16
phones so you don't know what any of
them are any of them could be your
favorite phone any of them could be
something you thought you loved or you
thought you hated you put them in a
bracket style format blind voting winner
moves on to the next round and we narrow
it all the way down to the People's
Choice best camera this is the blind
smartphone camera test 2021 so that's
exactly what we just did over on
Instagram for the past week brought
together 16 phones that all came out in
the last year and set them up seated
them in a bracket style you can find
them behind the scenes of us setting it
all up on the studio Channel if you're
not already subscribed over there by the
way you're really missing out what are
you doing that's all the behind the
scenes and all the fun projects you
could ever wish for and more but then we
took all the photos ran the side by
sides and got our winners and the winner
was well I'll get to that in a second
but how did we get there well here's the
bracket of all the letters that we
started with and here's what every
single one of those smartphones was at
the beginning now you might have already
voted over on Instagram either way I
saved that story on my profile so if you
go over there you can see the blind
smartphone camera test and you can see
each one and what you voted for but
let's go over how each one of those
rounds actually went so the first round
was a relatively simple picture of me in
the corner of the room but there's
actually a lot to the frame as you can
imagine so there's a subject in the
middle but also the window behind me was
a huge indicator of dynamic range
there's a blue mat with a painted
Android a gold helmet a red subscribe
pillow lots of details to go from here
so in the first round the Samsung Galaxy
S21 Ultra took down its little Ultra
brother the axon 30 Ultra then the
battle of the gaming phones the Rog
phone 5 dominated the legion gaming
phone the Sony Xperia Pro I somewhat
surprisingly defeated the Oppo Find X3
Pro and the OnePlus 9 Pro takes out the
flagship me 11 Ultra then the pixel 5A
took out the pixel 6 Pro in the pixel on
Pixel crime then iPhone gets its first
ever win in the history of this test for
four years with a first round win over
the Moto Edge then the Zenfone 8 crushed
the Poco X3 GT and the real me GT
squeaks out a win over the surface Duo
2. so
that is a lot and we definitely had some
interesting matchups set up in the first
round just to kind of see how they would
go some of these results did not
surprise me at all like the Galaxy S21
Ultra I think everything about that
photo was better than the ZTE it was
brighter it was crisper it had better
dynamic range everything about it not
surprised at one but some of them were
not as clear-cut like for the gaming
phone battle for example you know the
Rog phone I think it took a better photo
than the Legion phone especially with
dynamic range you can see that in the
background in the window behind me but
it did have some serious over hdre
looking issues that the legion didn't
have especially with this sort of halo
effect around my face and in the battle
of the pixels pixel 6 versus pixel 5A I
actually expected this slightly brighter
pixel 6 photo to win given all of the
things basically equal and also the
slightly blurrier background versus the
subject thanks to the bigger sensor but
the pixel 5A with these slightly more
balanced photo actually did get the win
also just a small note you can see me
smirking slightly in this one as the
photo gets taken with the surface Duo
too anyway second round the Rog phone
pulls off and upset and beats the Galaxy
S21 Ultra the OnePlus 9 Pro pretty
soundly beat the Sony Xperia Pro I the
pixel 5A ends the iPhone's run by
beating the 13 Pro and the realme GT I
think pulls off the biggest surprise
here by beating a parental contender in
the Zenfone 8 and really almost all of
these were closer battles here than the
first round mainly because this photo
just doesn't have that much to it right
it's flatter has less depth almost no
dynamic range challenge other than maybe
the candle and so this one just came
down to exposure and color I noticed the
warmer photos would make the candle and
the cookie appear a bit more saturated
but honestly in this round it was pretty
simple basically what we learned the
first time did win the test again in all
cases the brighter photo 1
so then in the semifinals we had OnePlus
9 Pro squeak out a victory over the Rog
phone five and then the Google pixel 5A
handily B the real me GT and this was a
really interesting one so you might have
already known or noticed this but Reds
are notoriously the hardest color for
these digital sensors to reproduce well
for a variety of reasons but that makes
a lot of differences in things like skin
tones and red threads and accents like
this but also when the whole photo is on
a red pool table and so this was a case
where how well you handled Reds really
mattered and actually in both cases the
brighter photo actually lost because
they were too bright they Overexposed
and so the photos that were a little
more neutral that had more reasonable
looking Reds ended up winning so then
the finals came down to the OnePlus 9
Pro and the pixel 5A raise your hand if
that's what you had written down at the
beginning as what your last two standing
would be doubt it so this one had
several skin tones a sky behind some
subjects in front of a distant
background and some album art Vibes for
sure and the winner of the blind
smartphone camera test in 2021 is Jay
the 399 dollar Google pixel 5A it
definitely won this last photo from
having more contrast and bringing in
more color from the sky I don't actually
think there's a clear answer to which
photo is better per se like the OnePlus
saturated skin tones more and had much
more Deep Shadows while the pixel was
pretty crunchy but didn't really let any
Shadows get totally dark and it was much
more hdre looking especially with the
faces but at the end of the day 75
percent of you picked the pixel as your
Champion The People's Choice blind
camera test winner so what did we learn
from this well first of all we've done
this test four years in a row now
running and it's been wild every time
this might be the last time we do it or
maybe we might shake it up and do it in
a different format next time we'll see
but with these tests we've picked up a
couple things and so have some of the
smartphone companies too number one
being that all other things held equal
in a side-by-side test people typically
pick the brighter photo as the winner
now that doesn't mean it's necessarily
the better photo that just you know it's
just a reflection of the format of the
test which is when you put two images
side by side typically people are just
drawn almost always to The Brighter one
then number two sharpness so while I
love a crispy photo uh it isn't
necessarily ever a factor in determining
which one of these photos wins and most
of that is because we do this test on
social media where compression kind of
erases any advantage you might have in
that sharpness department now a lot of
people always comment every year oh why
don't you put these like on Google Drive
somewhere so we can download them and
zoom in and pixel peep but that's kind
of not the point the point is it's just
a gut reaction of seeing a photo someone
posted online
somewhere on social media which is where
you typically see them so that's where
we posted it and then my latest Theory
the one I think is most interesting
number three is that it turns out most
people just want the most finished photo
out of their smartphone cameras so
there's a lot of data out there about
how people actually shoot photos on
their smartphones and it turns out most
of the time most people just take the
camera out of their pocket open the
camera app hit the shutter button they
don't even tap to focus and then that
image is the one that they're done with
they're going to share it they're going
to put it online they're going to text
it to their friends that unedited photo
done with that being said I always look
for patterns in these sort of things
anytime there's numbers and to me the
most interesting thing about this year's
test was that I looked at prices of the
phones that we used and it turns out the
price of the phone had almost nothing to
do with whether or not you guys voted
for it as the better or worse camera so
in the first round the more expensive
phone one five but lost three then in
the second round the more expensive
phone won zero times and lost all four
then in the semis it was an even split
one one and lost one and in the finals
yes the cheaper phone did actually win
it all this is one of the hardest videos
to make every year consistently it's
it's obviously the seating and the
planning and shooting all the photos and
getting it exactly right and then
posting them editing tallying all the
three million plus votes organizing
everything into our thoughts and really
finding out what we've learned each year
but it's always a lot of fun fun fact I
wanted to include Twitter again in the
voting alongside and Instagram but this
time the back end beta feature that was
enabled on my account for those previous
years thanks Twitter uh was actually
deleted it doesn't even exist anymore it
was allowing me to post images and polls
in a single tweet so I just did
everything on Instagram this year but at
the end of the day my question to you is
which one would you now pick as your
best smartphone camera now that you've
seen all the results and all the photos
from everyone if you're curious on how
we make these you might want to check
out the studio Channel but also you'll
probably be interested in my skillshare
class on how to make MKBHD videos
whether it's the explainers or the
product reviews or The Impressions all
of that in one place so skillshare is an
online learning community for creatives
with thousands of inspiring classes to
learn something you don't already know
things like photography or video editing
or Motion Graphics one of my favorite
things ever is the senior Motion
Graphics designer from YouTube channel
kurskazart made a skillshare class on
Motion Graphics I took a Motion Graphics
class in college
it wasn't nearly as good as this one so
I was pumped to go through that and I
highly recommend it as well and now I
watched the in a nutshell videos with
yet another Newfound level of respect
for the incredible videos this team
makes and skillshare is curated
specifically for learning so there's no
ads and they're always launching new
premium classes so you can stay focused
and follow your creativity wherever it
takes you so if you want to check this
stuff out definitely head to the link
below and the first thousand of you that
do that use my code will get one free
month of a skillshare premium membership
which is absolutely worth it so I'll see
you guys over there thanks for watching
catch you later peace
[Music]